[Music]
[Applause]
hello welcome everybody to this
afternoon session thanks for coming
we're here to talk about driving product
excellence based on feedback from users
like yourselves so my name is Jill Wars
I'm a user experience research leave in
G suite and a quantitative UX researcher
i am lindsay more i'm a qualitative user
experience researcher for google drive
I'm Joby is I'm a vice president chief
information officer of hingham
institution for savings and i'm ben
jerry i'm a qualitative user experience
researcher focused on the hangouts video
meeting experience so we're going to
talk to you today about how we
incorporate user feedback and to develop
products that we think work really well
for our users we think it's especially
important to keep our users needs in
mind when we're developing products for
productivity and collaboration so late
last year the UX director for G sweet
Lucas patent atty published an article
in Fast Company titled how to test
products like a Googler in this now it's
changing ok in this article you made the
argument that you should be collecting
feedback not just to make sure what
you're already working on is the right
thing to be working on and confirm your
direction instead you should be getting
feedback in order to figure out new
things you should be working on don't
cover new user needs and push your team
in new and creative directions so we
want to talk a little bit about how we
do this at Google so we're going to
start by sharing a little bit of an
inside look at how we focus on user
journeys rather than features and then
we're going to talk you through the
whole product feedback cycle from
uncovering user needs early on
collecting early feedback all the way
through to launch when we continue to
collect feedback via metrics and
analytics was I'm going to do a deep
dive into how team drives ran a user
feedback program to get their product to
the state that it's in today so we
believe that in order to build robust
excellent products you really need to
ensure that you're building products
that are going to meet your users needs
so we always have the end user in mind
before we even start building something
we're talking to users to find out what
problems they have and how we can help
solve those problems we want to know how
they're trying to get their work done we
want the products to be useful easy to
use and always reliable so we've moved
away from thinking about individual
features and instead we think about the
broader goals that our users have in
mind I'm going to give you a kind of a
silly example of this so how many of you
have heard of HD nobody okay so H day
was a day in 1967 when sweden switched
from driving on the left side of the
road to driving on the right side of the
road all over night who sounds kind of
crazy but i want you to imagine that
you're living outside of stockholm at
this time just before H day happens and
you have one goal in mind every morning
and that is to get to work on time so
you drive into work and it's pretty
straightforward every day you follow the
same roads you make the same turns maybe
you're spending more time admiring the
beautiful city around you then actually
thinking about how all these connections
go together but eventually you end up
with this one way road you turn down it
and great you're at work you made it
there on time you've accomplished your
goal now H day arrives and everything is
switched so you're going to be going to
work for the first time driving on the
other side of the road and you're pretty
worried about how this is going to work
you leave a little bit earlier than
usual maybe you're driving a little bit
slower than usual you might be driving
more carefully than usual but overall
you're finding that it's actually
working pretty well you're on the other
side of the road but you're still making
good time to work until you hit that one
way road close to your work and instead
of driving down it you see I do not
enter sign because the one-way road is
flipped in the opposite direction so why
am I talking about this it represents
exactly why we need to focus on journeys
instead of features because when we look
at each individual component of this
journey they all work the same way they
always did before so a two-way Road
still allows traffic's going to
directions signs mean the same thing
that they've always meant and your car
fundamentally works the same way that
have always worked the problem is when
you connect all these pieces together
you can no longer you can no longer
accomplish your goal of getting to work
on time because of that one little tweak
at the end so we look at the overall
picture of the journey and the user
fails at their goal so I want to take
this back to software development
we we know that our users don't think
about individual features they just
think about what they want to get done
at work and how they can be most
productive so imagine that you just want
to send a video to one of your
colleagues your goal is to get this
video to your colleague this sounds
simple enough but it actually used to be
kind of challenging in Gmail because of
the size limits on files that you could
attach to an email we've improved this
greatly and today when you attach a
large file to an email instead of it not
sending you are prompted uploaded to
drive and then prompted to share it with
your colleagues this might not be the
journey of you're expecting to take but
you're able to achieve your goal and
it's very easy for you to do that so
we've allowed people to get their work
done quickly so for some of you you
might be thinking great but I don't need
to send emails with videos to my
colleagues that's not like a fundamental
goal of what I do and we understand that
that's another really important point
here is that people in different roles
have different goals and they need to
accomplish different tasks take for
example example your sales
representatives they spend a lot of time
on the phone fundamentally they're all
about setting meetings getting feedback
from their customers and keeping track
of all those things maybe in a
spreadsheet your developers on the other
hand they're spending time heads down
writing code trying to build that next
great apps it can scale in response to
increased traffic their goal is just to
get that half out the door and make sure
that it's always up and running and then
finally your G sweet admin which is
probably some of you in this room you're
the buffer between your end users and
Google you're there to roll out new
products help people learn how to use
those products you might jump on video
to help them troubleshoot a new product
and you might jump into the cpanel to
understand who is adopting the product
and where you need to help people more
to start using the product so the
question now is how do we make sure that
we get all of these voices involved as
we're getting feedback from our
customers and I'm going to hand it over
to jail now for that great thanks Ben ok
so let's get into the heart of this talk
how we gather user feedback and then how
we leverage that to make an impact in
our products but before we do that I
want to get a sense of your experience
with user research and with providing
feedback to Google's so
have you ever please raise your hand
submitted feedback in products or
through surveys and products great
that's awesome to see how about
participated in a usability test wow
that's a lot more than I was expecting
awesome have you been observed by a
researcher in your workplace even a few
of those two that's great so we've had a
lot of different exposure to the UX
research and we're going to talk a
little bit more about all these
different methods and how we leverage
them within google we're going to break
this down into four different stages
from an early stage of discovery and
testing through trusted tester early
adopter and general availability and
throughout all of the examples that
we're talking about we're going to try
and point out exactly what impact our
research has had on those products
because it's really important to us that
whatever research we do does have an
impact we know that your time is
valuable and we want to make sure that
we can leverage that saying that I'm not
going to be able to provide and pointed
evidence of all the impact that we've
had because some of this research has
just been too recent and obviously we
can't talk about product direction so
bear with me there okay so let's dive
into the earliest stage at this point
we're defining new products with
flashing out the feature set we're
pinning down the details of those
products there are two main types of
research that we do at this point I'll
give you an example of a discovery type
an example of a testing type of research
but before that who has heard of eat
your own dog food okay so quite a lot of
people so the premise behind this is
before we give our products to users we
should be using them ourselves right and
luckily we have a lot of Googlers who
care about our products and so they will
take time working on working with really
early stage products that it really
rough around the edges they probably
have lots of bugs in them it might not
be quite usable just yet but they will
give us really opinionated and critical
feedback they do not hold back and that
helps us move that product for words it
helps us I and out those rough edges and
it helps us fix a lot of those early
bugs but we know that Google is aren't
like rg3 users right in many ways one
example if a googler is trying to create
a document or a spreadsheet or
presentation typically we use our G
sweet editors to do that and we know
that for a lot of our customers on the
other hand Microsoft is still part and
parcel of their their work date so if we
just focus on Googlers we wouldn't
understand how our products interface
with Microsoft products so there's one
example where we really need to get
outside of Google so we do we want to
figuratively peer in two different
workplaces to understand what's
happening in our users lives and there
were three reasons why we want to do
this we want to understand their user
journeys we want to understand what
they're trying to achieve what tools
they're using whether it's our tools or
other tools what schools are using to do
that the flip side of that is of course
what's holding the back what are the
obstacles what are the opportunities
that we have to improve those user
journeys and then certainly we can also
get some really great early feedback
about new products if we're thinking if
we have a potential idea we can test it
out with our users does it resonate with
them okay so the first two
at these we're going to we're going to
use this the first method the discovery
type method and that's going to give us
a lot of insight into those first two
types so I'm this discovery this
exploratory phase we're really trying to
get a holistic understanding we want to
see how people work in the workplace
relative to their team relative to the
organization as a whole when they're
working by themselves and this example
this photo is taken from an example a
few years ago we took a number of
Engineers product managers designers as
well as researchers into multiple
companies across the US and
internationally too and we gave them
this guidebook and you know it kind of a
guide them through questions that they
can ask people that we mean things to
look out for and they have a place to
write down notes which we then brought
back into Google and we could share
between us so there were two really
awesome outcomes the first of these was
we got our engineers our product team
talking with our end users and that
enables those are engineers to really
gain empathy and understanding of our
users it's one of the most powerful
tools that we have as researchers the
flip side of that of course is we have a
ton of data so we troll through all of
that data and there was so much
information in there bugs that needed to
be fixed feature requests but then we
also started to see high-level patents
and one of those high level patents was
that you know even three or four years
ago when we did this study mobile was
ubiquitous in the workplace and that
brought us to start focusing on mobile
to ensure that we have parity between
our mobile and desktop products and you
know we're at the point now where I can
take my phone I can start a document I
can leave comments on somebody else's
months I can collaborate with my team
wherever I am so we we really see this
long-term impact from this kind of
research so that's the discovery
research on the opposite side we have
testing so we do iterative research on
early-stage concept or even later stage
products what we just need to figure out
to user interaction with this product we
need to iron out those edges and we have
individuals either come in to Google or
we we interview them over video chat as
well and we get them to walk through a
scenario using either the concepts or
the product and get them to do that
representative task so that we can see
how they perform that task and you know
there's a number of different things we
can pull out of that we get a sense of
does the concepts resonate with them is
this a problem that our users are
actually trying to solve does the
current setup is it usable can people
achieve that goal and then we also just
get to hear other concerns and other
feedback and so from this we get to we
get really early feedback that can help
us from the direction of our product and
give us confidence that we are heading
in the right direction we run these
these studies every week across the u.s.
across the world and so of course that
means that we always need more people to
test with so if you would like to join
with us and provide feedback in that
manner we will love to have you sign up
there's a couple more QR codes at the
back of the room on the way out to this
research panel is 4g sweet end users
we're looking for companies who will
find out we can't promise that everybody
will be able to join the panel at this
stage the
that is a pilot but we're hoping to get
lots of people signing up so that we can
continue to do this early stage research
and allow you to have an impact in our
product direction and with that i'm
going to hand it back over to Ben so I'm
going to tell you a little bit about the
next couple areas where we get feedback
these are trusted testers and early
adopter programs which are more formal
collaborations with small groups of our
users in both of these phases we work
with a cross-section of businesses
different sizes different verticals to
try and be as representative of the kind
of people that we work with every day as
we possibly can we're really focused on
fit and finish rather than discovering
new product directions but you'll see
there are some times where we make some
interesting tweaks to our product I'm
going to use the new hangouts video
meeting experience as the example here
when we kicked off this project we
really wanted to take a fresh new look
on how we could build an enterprise
focus video meeting software that would
work well across web mobile and in the
in-room experience dedicated meeting
rooms and we wanted to focus on
identifying those like core pain points
that people experience with the
offerings today eliminate those and make
a product that would really make for
effective meetings so we started with
that early discovery work that Jill
mentioned already and to really key
parts here were field visits and
interviews so with field visits we were
able to actually go out for some of our
customers and observe them using their
existing software to complete video
meetings we were able to see these
social interactions and what makes them
eating really flow and what's important
what's important to making a meeting
productive we've ended deep dive
interviews with some of the people who
participated in those meetings to
understand how much those those problems
come out like how frequently do they
encounter those problems and what are
the sort of common themes they see in
terms of trying to make their meetings
more productive when we learn to really
interesting things here the first is
that people really care about big
meetings they don't want to have to
worry about the number of people they're
inviting to a meeting they just wanna be
able to have as many people in that
meeting as possible the second is that
they really care about people being able
to get into the meeting easily and this
doesn't just mean
we should do a great job of getting
people into a video meeting it also
means that we have to open it up to
people who are dialing in on their
phones so to meet market needs we need
to make it so that if you have somebody
who's traveling and doesn't have a good
Wi-Fi connection or you have a customer
who just doesn't like showing up on
video conferencing they're able to
connect to your meeting as well these
were two things that we sort of
incorporated into our work in building
and designing this new product I'm going
to skip over the phase where we did some
usability testing and dog food in here
and jump right into our trusted tester
program so trusted tester is an
invite-only program where you x products
and sales works really closely together
to identify a small subset of our users
who are willing to sort of take the risk
to work with us with a product that's
not fully fleshed out yet we want people
who are responsive constructively
critical willing to give lots of
feedback and also willing to experiment
with us a little bit as they try out
these products we asked for a lot of
regular feedback and we're working very
very closely with our admins at this
point but we think that there's a
mutually beneficial relationship here
because the admins also get the chance
to see a new product and really be
involved in with the roadmap for that
product so we engage closely with G
sweet admins trying to build up their
confidence that they can roll this
product product out to all of their end
users the goal is time to roll it out to
everybody in their company so that they
can then bubble up as much feedback as
possible from their end users to say how
well the product is working in
supporting user needs so this gives us
chance to kind of test the products in
the wild and see what user journeys
people are taking with it in this case
we also did some observations so once
they had rolled the product out to their
end users we went out and actually watch
them participating in meetings with the
new hangouts video meeting experience
and then conducted some surveys to
understand how it compared to their past
experiences and again we got some
interesting insights here sitting in on
those meetings we saw that it almost
every meeting people have with lots of
people joining on video somebody joins
with their mic not muted from a loud
room or from a bus station or something
and this is really disruptive you sub
may have somebody with a lot of
background noise joining a meeting so we
realized what we needed to do is make it
really easy to quiet that person down
and
try and remove that disruption so we
took the time to rework the UI and make
it much quicker to find the controls for
muting somebody who joins a meeting so
you have as a meeting host you have more
control over the meeting experience we
think it's small tweaks like these that
can really make for an optimal
experience for our users we love working
with our trusted testers like I said
it's a small group of admins and their
end-users there's a kind of people who
we can just email out of the blue and
they'll respond to us they know who we
are we work closely but what they can't
do is tell us how the product is going
to work at scale so for that we need to
use ourselves into general availability
and get broader feedback so we move into
our early-adopter programs the core
question is how does it work at scale by
the time the product is in the early
adopter program it should be pretty
stable we know that it's really hard to
deal with change management as an admin
so we want our admins to know that they
can roll this products out and it's just
going to work and support all the use
cases of their users they should be
confident that it'll work for everybody
they understand that we're not going to
make big changes and we know that if we
did make big changes that would be
really difficult on them so we announced
in the fall of 2016 that we were going
into the early adopter program with the
new hangouts video meeting experience
and we've really been focused on fit and
finish we're now in the process of
collecting and product feedback tracking
bugs and really just seeking feedback
via surveys to see what more we need to
do to make this even better the next
stuff is going to be general
availability and we're not there yet but
we're not going to stop collecting
feedback when we do go to general
availability so it's really important
for us to know how it's working in the
real world we'll keep doing we'll keep
checking on bugs we'll keep tracking in
product feedback but more importantly we
will also sort of kick off the cycle
again and start thinking about what the
next product is that we might build in
this space I'm going to hand it over to
jail now to defer an example of how this
doesn't always work out exactly as
planned
Thank You Ben so of course right you
could put up this great create this
great process but then something will
come along that doesn't really fit into
that process it for us that was John
board and that's because Jam board isn't
just about great software it's about
testing and producing great hardware as
well so for those of you who haven't
seen Jenn boards it's google's take on
the digital whiteboard we're trying to
enable easier team collaboration so if
you haven't touched Chambord i believe
there's one just out in the corridor
here go play with it afterwards but you
can see you can draw you can write on
this Chambord you can insert images
virtual stickies all sorts of different
objects and you can also access our jam
board remotely through other devices so
because we're talking about hardware
here we have to get really creative
about process that we were using so
instead of going through trusted tester
and then an EAP we decided to work
really closely with a few very select
partners we would go into their de
partners offices we would observe people
using jam board we also observe them
when they weren't using down boards
right when they were doing brainstorming
or other collaborative work but they
chose not to include John boards we also
interviewed users individually to get
more focused feedback and understand how
jam board fit into the user journeys and
we also interviewed IT admins because
again like Ben was saying we understand
that the itm and is is like wandering
right it's IT admins are going to be the
key to the success of deploying and
managing John boards out in the wild
alright so we've talked about early
stage research we've talked about
trusted tester how that's like the first
time that it sees the customer on scale
but it's still my change a little bit
we've seen early access programs where
what the product is more finalized and
of course once we launch we don't just
stop there right i methods of research
of gathering user feedback just change
we now have bigger scales so use in
product feedback we use in product
surveys as well that information is
really important to us we have teams
that will process that feedback that
creates groupings that categorize that
feedback so that we can understand both
whether there are new problems arising
whether we fix the problems that we were
trying to fix and just to understand
what's going on with our users and we
can also look at behavior actual
behavior in the product what are people
doing what features are they engaging
with and triangulating all these
different sources of data or feedback
can help us then prioritize the product
roadmap moving ahead and I do want to
point out you know one of the one of the
surveys we do send out regularly every
quarter is to IT admins and developers
because as we've said multiple times
already through this presentation we
know that you have very specific user
journeys that it's critical for to us
that we understand your pain points and
your needs so that we can ensure that
our products get rolled out successfully
to the end users so if you do see this
in your inbox please consider taking
time to fill it out so we've talked
about the four different stages I want
to mention to being a quantitative
researcher that we also take into
account quantitative feedback through
all four of these stages and by
quantitative feedback I mean metrics and
one way that we use metrics is by
pulling together that quantitative
information with the qualitative
feedback that we've got from our users
to make sure that we're ready to move
from one of these stages to the next
stage are we ready to go from trusted
tester to EA
p are we ready to go to general access
and we want to think beyond just click
through rates from page views at this
point too and so one of the ways that we
do that at Google is by using this
framework with a very cute acronym it's
talking about the range of different
metrics that we should be thinking about
when we're considering user or
considering measuring how our users are
interacting with our product there are
five areas here I'm going to focus on
just two and these two are the ones that
I've seen come up again and again as we
as we push new products out so retention
retention is all about long-term
engagement there's a person keep coming
back and for different products we
expect different levels of engagement
over time right for gmail if you're
anything like me I'm in there multiple
times a day for presentations not quite
as often I'm not senior enough yet I do
a lot of other work too so it's not
about how often people are coming back
but that that number stays pretty stable
over time right we're keeping people
coming back at a certain rate so for
gmail it might be everyday presentations
every week or every month and the gmail
examples a little forced here because
people we know that our end users they
have to do email they have no choice
about the master I they have to be in
gmail checking their email for the
majority of our GC customers and so
that's why we also want to look at
happiness so happiness is about user
opinions it's how how happy is a user
often we use satisfaction as a measure
of this you'll probably see that in in
product surveys how satisfied are you
with this products on a scale of one to
five from very happy or very satisfied
very unsatisfied and we tracked those
metrics over time for our existing
products we want to make sure that
they're you know steadily increasing and
we also said
all for those four new products and new
features that we want to launch so hard
can tell us about the breadth of metrics
that we're interested in using one
principle that overrides all of these
five areas is that our metrics should be
aligned with the goals that we have for
our user and by that I mean how are we
trying to help our user achieve their
user journey we also want to take into
account who that user is as part of that
too so to illustrate that in an example
let's talk about Google Sites so we
released a new version of Google Sites
late last year and one of the user goals
as part of this release was that it was
easier for people to create sites to
share information and so instead of just
looking at you know how often did
somebody click on a page that was a new
site versus an old site we tried to
align it with this idea of creating
sites so one of the metrics we looked at
was we asked people who created the site
so that was our user type how easy it
was to do that and then we compared that
with how easy people reported it was to
create sites through the old to through
the old version of the products and
another metric that was associated with
that user goal was around retention the
next time that person had to create
another site did they do so with the new
products or did they choose to go back
to the old product so we had that
happiness and retention metrics and with
those two metrics along with user
feedback we thought we could safely make
a decision to launch that product
alright so just to recap we have these
four stages the early stage testing and
discovery releasing to our trusted
testers where you know things might
change a little bit then early adopter
program where we're releasing it more
widely with the the assumption that
things aren't going to change too much
right we're just doing a little
polishing a little fixing before we
launch and then finally launching to
general availability and at that I'd
like to invite Lindsay to come and talk
about team drives so um to start can I
get a show of hands of anyone here not
heard of team drives okay so a couple so
um to catch to catch you up if you're
not familiar with it um team drives our
new collaborative spaces in Google Drive
and they live parallel to my drive but
they're specifically created with teams
in mind and they're designed around
three core tenants so first file stay
after employees lead the company second
the shearing rules are much simpler than
the sharing roles in drive today and
then lastly they get your team's content
all in one place so with team drives
shared spaces now look the same for
everyone new members joining a team
automatically get access to the content
they need right away and files don't go
missing accidentally so with team drives
we went through each of those phases of
getting user feedback that Ben and Jill
described as we were progressing towards
general availability and through those
phases we had three main goals so we
needed to determine whether team drives
as a feature was fit for launch and we
also needed to understand what works
well or maybe what doesn't work well
when customers start to use team drives
for their actual day-to-day
collaboration and then lastly we really
wanted to gather longitudinal feedback
about how domain
and teams and users within those domains
incorporate team drives into their
workflow and then how would they use it
differently from shared folders so can I
get another show of hands how many of
you are from domains that participated
in our early adopter program 14 drive
anybody cool that's awesome okay so
early adopter program or EAP it was our
first large-scale test of team drive and
at first was with around 100 domains and
later thousands of domains and we were
gathering both qualitative and
quantitative data that we could use to
evaluate our success metrics engage our
lunch readiness and it was significant
because it represented the first time a
large amount of GC admins could start
testing out team drives and thinking
about how to deploy it within their
domains and then also it was significant
in that we had to sign up customers at
scale we were getting feedback at scale
we were responding to that feedback at
scale and that took an immense amount of
coordination across many different
groups at Google so like I said we
initially started out our early-adopter
program with just under 100 domains and
it was an internationally representative
group of customers range of sizes range
of industries all different types of
companies and as a requirement for
getting access during this early part of
our early adopter program customers had
to be willing to give access to team
drives to at least some of their non IT
users and and also to have those users
participate in some feedback surveys so
we knew that when we give access to team
drives we could rely on g sweet admins
to you know give us their feedback as i
started trying it out and thinking about
how they were planning on deploying it
but we also really needed to balance
that with feedback from end users as
well so for example we wanted to be able
to measure whether we are hitting our
success metrics around adoption and
engagement so we're users actually
trying team drives did
come back to it and try it again after
they tried at that first time and we
needed to understand was it actually
addressing the user and team and domain
level needs that it was intended to
address and was it generating
satisfaction so because of this we ran a
survey with both admins and users and we
did that before anyone has access to
team dress and that became our baseline
for things like satisfaction happiness
and then we ran another survey after
people who had tried team drive for a
few weeks so that way we were able to
get a good baseline and then you know
use that to evaluate success and through
those surveys we were also able to get
an understanding of the whys behind the
usage metrics we saw so why were people
using team drives or not using team guys
so thank you so much for those of you
who are participated in this early
phases of our early early adopter
program and participated in surveys and
had your users participate in surveys
it's just such a valuable source of
events for us so what have we learned
from our early adopter program for team
drives well in addition to a host of
useful feedback we had two big takeaways
and one of those was around change
management so we often talk about change
management at the domain level right so
as we work with G sweet admins to
understand what's needed for domains to
change their processes or deploy new
products of features and educate users
but in our EAP we heard that teams
themselves need change management so
with the future like team drives is
designed for teams and the whole team
needs to be coordinated and have
critical mass to actually make a switch
of that magnitude of switch in their
processes are on where they're storing
their team's content so we've worked to
incorporate onboarding into the feature
that helps teams understand team drives
as they get started with using it the
other was a confirmation that being able
to migrate your team's existing content
into team drives is really crucial for
adoption so today teams have their
Google Drive content in large shared
folder structures with a lot of
different file owners and both GC admins
and users need the ability to easily
files they don't own and folders full of
files they don't own into a team drive
for admins often it's this initial bulk
content migration trying to get
everything into team drives for the
first time but also in larger domains um
you know those admins need certain users
or maybe even all their users to help
them with the scale of that task and
then a lot of companies cultures you
know the team's themselves need to be
able to move their existing folders of
content into team drives as needed
without having to involve their GC admin
so we were working to address these
findings and we reached out to customers
who had previously contacted us with
feedback you know about that very thing
about content migration we needed to
make sure we were going to get the
experience right for admins and users
across different kinds of domains you
know different expectations around
access or sharing or the need for
control so really the ability to reach
back out to customers like this is a
important part of what makes trusted
tester and early adopter program so
powerful we're really trying to create a
relationship cultivate that relationship
where we are able to have a
back-and-forth conversation about our
products and features so one of those
customers that we reached out to was
hingham institution for savings which is
a community bank in the boston area so i
will now bring joe bears who is the cio
at him up on stage and we'll hear from
him about what it was like to
participate in giving feedback to google
so everyone so we understand that you
guys are trying to transition more fully
into the cloud and moving to g sweet is
a protocol so that's why that's
important for him for multiple reasons
server consolidation being one of them
and disaster recovery with g sweet we've
been able to get out of the business of
maintaining service we've cut down about
a third of our service and I'm we're not
doing things like back up on them
anymore to an antivirus updates things
of that nature and spend what instead we
were able to take more time you know
advancing the company goals doing things
that help our customers so why its rise
how is drive an important piece of that
drives brought a lot of sharing and
collaboration
previously with our old productivity
suite we were you know somebody would go
in would have a group of people that
needed to update something and to go in
try to update it and tell them that it
was a read-only copy that would result
in news is ending up having to make a
copy and then would all have somebody
would have to come along and roll back
all those changes into one copy when I'm
Google now we're able to everybody can
work on at the same time so there's a
lot more collaboration and it saves a
lot of efficiencies so um why did you
guys want to be part of the early
adopter program for team drive initially
when we em when we set up the M when we
got into drive we uh we needed to have a
common area just to share all the data
and what we did there was we created
what I call a service account and with
that service account we replicated out
fold the structure into it and then from
there we shed all that out when we saw
team drives come along we knew it looked
like what we were actually trying to
accomplish yeah so it sounds like that
that wasn't obstacle for management and
yeah few guys was more like well yeah
that's exactly what we were looking for
yeah so what did you do when you first
got access team drive we started by
setting it up in one of our back offices
and we were in with that for
approximately a month two months and I'm
from there we started spreading out and
moving it to different departments it
really rolled out quite easy from the oh
we even had some some of our on branches
even set up their own team drives and
migrated the data on their own so it
worked really well so speaking of users
how did you introduce team drives to
then like how did you orient people to
just a totally new file sharing system
it's been a pretty smooth transition we
um we started by replicating the whole
folder structure that was on our old
servers and from there we are yeah I'm
sorry I lost my own you know from there
you know we rolled it out to everybody
I'm working through a web browser really
didn't turn out to be that much of a
difference in working through file
explorer so it really wasn't a huge
change great so how have people been
using team drive so far the best way to
explain it as sharing and collaboration
like I said everybody is able to do work
a lot smoother and
more efficiently so on it's really
worked out well on that son and if you
have any like specific use cases from a
team at hingham that you can share with
us probably a human resources department
the onboarding process it used to be a
process where they human resources would
send emails around and it attached like
the onboarding form and now with team
drives they're just setting it up within
the team Drive folders and then there
they send out a notification via team
drives and I'm that I everybody just
goes in and works on it as a Navy and
then as a Nam the process was getting
held up before and it's no longer
getting held up it's great that's a good
here so um like I mentioned earlier
hingham had ended up participating in
this follow-up study we did at some
point during our early-adopter program
about content migration so why did you
guys want to participate again in that
well we want to have input like I said
we had that that user the utility user
as i call it set up then I we have data
in and we want to have input on how to
get that data out of the utility user
and move it over into the team Drive
folders additionally we're changing as a
company and we we want to have more
partners that are open to feedback we
have other partners that we give
feedback to and not great at responding
to contrast that we actually have one
partner that's involved in doing a
licensing on it with us and it's not
really helping advance the company's
goal it's more like a sales tactic so
it's great to have google and they're
listening to a feedback and we see it
show up very quickly in the products for
your for your users themselves would it
make it out of participating in
something like this a lot of odd users
actually commented to me that they enjoy
doing the hope they enjoyed the whole
process of giving feedback and some of
them we actually said they learn more
about the product and the process so
that was a really great thing so when
you participate in an early adopter
program like you did it's not a finished
product right so how does that impact
you like what are your thoughts on you
know using products that aren't fully
finished we don't mind we em realize
that that's that's something that's
going to occur with a new product like
that and we've made a decision as a
company that we want to be more on the
leading edge of technology like that
instead of a trailing edge where stuff
is more fully fleshed out but you know
it it works great for us so so just to
wrap up what does it mean for an
organization like hingham to be involved
in this feedback process with google it
means a lot to us it's great that a
small company like oz can have feedback
into a product like Google's creating we
have other we have another data center
that we're constantly trying to give
feedback to and they don't really listen
with a they asked for the feedback and
it we never see it get into the product
so it's great to see it you know see the
changes that we ask for end up in the
product well thank you so much Joe for
coming here and uh speaking this awful
today and sharing hands experience with
the team drives early a doctor program
we really appreciate it and then for
those of you in the audience who were
part of that really doctor program as
well thank you so much for you know
being part of it taking the time to show
your feedback with us thank you so what
does it mean to test products like a
Googler it means we are always looking
for feedback on our products no matter
what stage of the developments like over
in and we're always looking for new ways
to engage our customers and pull in
their value feedback we're really just
in constant motion through this research
cycle with each of our products and in
order for us to get this valuable user
feedback it's really vital that we have
partners to work with so without their
help which is essentially your help this
would be much harder so if you are
interested like Jill said earlier in
having your company join our G sweet
user panel so we can include your end
users in our early iterative studies for
example on follow this link up here on
the left so you can sign up an express
interest and then for any of you in the
audience who r.i.p professionals or
developers you can also sign up using
the link on the right to help product
development on Google cloud platform so
in either case it's like a quick little
5-minute survey you'll get your name in
our database
and we can't promise we'll be able to
include everyone in our panels but we're
really continually looking for more
participants for our studies and we
really look forward to getting your
feedback so we can continue to drive
product excellence within G sweet thank
you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]